tf1 20 heures avec dominique baudis
madame de gaulle sera enterré à
colombey-les-deux-églises samedi
prochain aux côtés du général de gaulle
et de sa fille émotion après la mort de
l'épousé général pour tf1 les
témoignages de ceux qui l'ont connu jean
matteoli nouveau ministre du travail il
était président des charbonnages de
france iran contact entre l'envoyé du
président carter et l'ol paie en vue de
négocier la libération des otages
américains
bonsoir madame de gaulle la compagne du
général s'était éteinte
aux premières heures de ce jour comme
lui elle disparaît dans sa 79e année à
la veille du 9 novembre qui devait
marquer demain
l'anniversaire de la mort du général de
gaulle elle savait que ces jours que ces
heures était désormais compté et ses
proches l'ont vu lutter contre le mal
elle leur a confié qu'elle désirait
mourir le même jour que l'homme auquel
elle avait lié son destin
ils reposeront désormais côte à côte à
colombey-les-deux-églises à quelques pas
de cette demeure dont ils avaient fait
leur refuse ces murs de la boisserie
abritait un univers dont il avait
toujours soigneusement protéger
l'intimité
demain à l'occasion de l'anniversaire de
la mort du général de gaulle les portes
de la boisserie devait s'ouvrir au
public ce sera la fin de la viola bilité
de ce lieu les deux êtres qui l'habitait
ont quitté ce monde au destin duquel ils
ont été si étroitement associées
il était 1h30 ce matin lorsque madame de
gaulle 7 est apte à l'hôpital du val de
grâce
jean pierre à bot
c'est dans une de ses chambres au
troisième étage de l'hôpital du val de
grâce que madame de gaulle s'est éteint
de ce matin 1h30
hier soir encore madame de gaulle était
consciente elle a reconnu ses enfants et
leur a dit au revoir c'est tard dans la
soirée qu'elle est entré dans le coma
son fils l'amiral philippe de gaulle a
été le premier ce matin à venir se
recueillir devant la dépouille de sa
mère madame de gaulle avait été
hospitalisée le 18 octobre
ses proches ne cachaient pas leur très
vive inquiétude quant à l'issue de sa
maladie depuis un an madame de gaulle
avait quitté la propriété de la
boisserie à colombey les deux églises et
est devenue une des trente deux
pensionnaires de cette maison de
retraite des soeurs de l'immaculée
conception a vu d'abord donné à paris
c'était une femme discrète qui souriait
souvent et qui se confiait peu
la chaleur des choses comme ça mais elle
nous réserve ne parlait jamais de se
marier à lombez les deux églises de sa
vie passée ça vous cultiver comme toutes
les autres pensionnaires nuage est
revenu exactement par l'éloigner
tellement familières promis en fin de
matinée l'amiral philippe de gaulle est
venu à la maison de retraite où sa mère
habitait une chambre minuscule meublé de
bois blancs madame de gaulle n'avait
absolument rien emporter de la boisserie
pas un objet seulement quelques photos
souvent le dimanche et de retourner à
colombey-les-deux-églises pour aller
prier dans le petit cimetière
la nouvelle de sa mort a profondément
attristé les habitants de
colombey-les-deux-églises messieurs vous
ne vous recueillir sur la tombe du
général vous savez que madame de gaulle
vient de mourir
est décédé ce matin pour présenter pour
vous madame de gaulle
quelle femme était même de gaulle selon
pas égaux rendent très grande femme
vraiment madame vous semblait bouleversé
parce que madame de gaulle représenter
quelque chose de particulier pour vous
je m'y attendais pas
comment quelques mots pouvez vous
qualifier ce qu était la veuve du
général de gaulle en quelques mots
qu'est ce qu'elles représentent les plus
grands sa compagne
et quel rôle at-elle joué au près de lui
selon d'anciens
la soupe au lait
quant à l'homme de gaulle a quitté que
lombez pour partir à paris
qu'avez vous ressenti vous avez compris
qu'elle quitte la boisserie et
dernièrement alors tout le monde amis
choc là beaucoup de choses mais aussi de
sa mort parce que c'était si bonne si
bonne dame qu'elle est aimée de tout le
monde et tout le monde a eu de la peine
de la voir partir les biens années
qu'elle finisse et joule à colombie vous
étiez très proche du général et d'une
âme de gueule alors pouvez vous nous
parler de madame de gaulle qui
était-elle elle était assez discrète on
la connaissait pas dire oui on la
connaissait pas bien mais enfin tous les
français la connaissent
vous savez qui lui avait trouvé à un nom
affectueux qui était celui de tortis
bonne et je crois que si vous parlez de
tante yvonne à français dans la rue il
se rate qu'il s'agit non sa discrétion
elle tenait au fait qu'elle voulait se
conserver une vie de famille elle
voulait maintenir autour du général
une zone de sécurité et de calme
elle souhaitait plus générale pu se
retrouver ici dans cette maison
comme un homme
normal comme un chef de famille entourée
de ses enfants et ses petits enfants et
s'est employée elle s'est employée toute
son existence à maintenir cette sécurité
autour de lui et je crois que c'est en
grande partie en raison de sa discrétion
le général de gaulle écrivait d'elle ma
femme sans qui rien de ce qui a été fait
n'aurait pu l'être
un témoignage qui exprime toute la
richesse d'une vie commune longue de 49
ans une existence qui pour yvonne de
gaulle était faite de discrétion de
dignité et de sens du devoir
chagin collins apparemment rien ne
destinait yvonne vendroux à devenir une
personnalité publique
née au début du set dans une famille de
petits industriels de calais elle avait
été élevée dans la tradition de la
bourgeoisie du nord elle s'était mariée
en 1921 avec charles de gaulle jeune
capitaine de 30 ans qui était à ce
moment là professeur d'histoire
militaire à saint cyr
physiquement il était très dissemblables
il faisait un mètre 94 1 m 58
mais ils avaient en commun leur région
d'origine leur religion le respect de
l'effort un certain mépris du luxe un
nationalisme pointilleux qui engendrait
déjà une certaine idée de la france
de leur union était née trois enfants
philippe qui fait une carrière dans la
marine
elisabeth et anne cette dernière une
enfant diminué à laquelle il était très
attaché et qui mourut à 20 ans plutôt
qu'à venir de nature yvonne de gaulle
suivi sans broncher son mari dans les
différentes étapes de sa carrière
jusqu'en angleterre où elle le rejoignit
en 1940 avec ses enfants à la libération
c'est le retour en france et l'accession
du général aux plus hautes
responsabilités de l'état madame de
gaulle se plier aux obligations de sa
fonction sans y prendre apparemment
satisfaction elle reçoit cependant les
grands et les moins grands de ce monde
avec la même aisance affable peu
coquette de nature elle fait l'effort de
se coiffer de s'habiller comme il
convient la première dame de france tout
en conservant une certaine simplicité
provincial et de gaulle avait acheté en
1934 une maison à colombes et en haute
marne
yvonne de gaulle s'y retrouvent toujours
avec plaisir quand le général était à
l'elysée ou quand il s'est retiré des
affaires publiques de 1949 à 58 ou en
à ce moment là on vit tout le temps sa
silhouette déjà un peu vieillissante aux
côtés du général en espagne et en
irlande après son départ de l'elysée
yvonne de gaulle n'a jamais eu de rôle
politique officielle mais il a certain
qu'elle a une influence sur son mari
quoi qu'il soit très difficile de dire
exactement laquelle il plaisantait
volontiers le tricotage qui était pour
lui le symbole de la signifiance mais il
était on sait très attaché aux valeurs
morales et familiales dont elle était la
figure lorsque son mari disparu en
novembre 1970 elle resta seul à colombes
et maintenant sans défaillance
l'attitude de dignité et de silences qui
avait toujours été la sienne évitant
toute manifestation publique très
fatigué s'était installée l'année
dernière dans une maison de retraite
parisienne partagé entre la piété et les
visites de ses enfants et de ses petits
enfants une vie qui aurait pu être la
sienne s'il n'avait été pendant près de
50 ans la compagne attentif du plus
grand homme politique de son époque
cet après midi madame valérie giscard
d'estaing s'est rendu à l'hôpital du
val-de-grâce pour se recueillir devant
la dépouille mortelle de madame de
gaulle
de son côté le chef de l'état déclare
qu'il s'incline respectueusement au nom
du peuple français devant celle qui a
partagé avec une dignité et une
discrétion exemplaire la vie du général
de gaulle dans la gloire et dans les
épreuves
les réactions sont innombrables
messieurs jacques chirac jacques chaban
delmas michel debré olivier guichard le
premier ministre monsieur raymond barre
qui a fait porter de lettres
personnelles aux enfants de madame de
gaulle
je vous propose maintenant d'entendre
quelques témoignages de personnes
l'ayant très bien connu le premier sera
celui de madame georges pompidou
j'avais vu régulièrement depuis
quarante-quatre toujours
à toutes les époques très très
régulièrement et je crois qu'elle
m'aimait bien et que l avait aussi
beaucoup d'amitié pour mon mari elle
nous l'a souvent prouvé et elle nous
soutenaient et apprécié et nous
soutenaient quand c'était utile
c'était tout à l'heure vous avez même
employer le terme affection quand oui je
crois qu'ils avaient une campagne locale
landes contre vous vous avez été lavé
les affections je suis certaine disent
également que vous receviez vous avez
gardé toutes ces lettres qu'elle vous
écrivez un courrier assez important
parce que c'était pas une personne qui
téléphonaient c'est quelqu'un qui
écrivait comme moi j'aime bien écrire
aussi on s'est écrit assez souvent
alors dans la période où le général
était prise au pouvoir en se voyaient
souvent parce que c'était un temps
d'arrêt de se faire une ode à
l'université et de collombey et on
allait à colombelles général est venu
dîner aussi kate béthune plusieurs fois
et nous perdons religieusement je garde
religieusement son autographe sur le sur
mon livre d'or il est le seul d'ailleurs
un on n'a pas voulu faire signer
quelqu'un de l'autre ensuite
et puis l heure après dans la période
suivante qui était la période de mon
mari était à matignon qui a duré presque
sept ans naturellement on a eu des corps
des contacts constants bien sûr
officielles et non officielles mais
toujours dans la grande amitié
vous avez été reçu par même de gaulle
juste après la mort du général juste
après la mort du général je suis allé
lui rendre visite à collombey et nous
étions dans la pièce
le général est mort et elle m'a raconté
avec la plus grande simplicité
comment il était s'était effondré de son
fauteuil en faisant sa réussite
elle m'a dit tout ça avec tant de
simplicité que
et à l'heure c'était pathétique et quand
je suis rentré à l'elysée le soir que
j'ai raconté cette visite à mon mari
vraiment nous étions très très ému je le
suis encore on y pense ça je les sous
vont avoir à l'elysée quand ton mari
était premier ministre et faisons
déjeunions
avec elle et avec le général temps en
temps il habita les enfants pour les
enfants pour le connaître des
connotations ciné passion personnelle
vous m'avez dit pour moi c'était le
modèle de la femme de l'homme politique
dont elle trouve que c'est qu'on vit
exactement comment doit se conduire
enfin un politique c'est à dire le banc
beaucoup à la machine est elle une vie
de famille très unie et je me sens
jamais en avant en étant toujours un
petit peu en arrière
discrète et très mesuré très distraite
comme tout le monde j'ai beaucoup de
chagrin parce que je me demande si ce
type de femme
se retrouvera encore en france je ne
sais pas jours qu'elle a incarné une
image de la france qui est à tellement
loin de ce que nous pouvons voir
aujourd'hui chez les jeunes dans la rue
dans ces têtes on peut encore une fois
et mais autre chose mais moi je trouve
que cette espèce de permanence qu'elle
incarne et d'une france bourgeoise
austère morale vertueuse est une chose
quand même qui devient de plus en plus
rare parce que même les gens qui sont
comme ça n'ose plus avoir l'air de
l'être vis-à-vis du général à votre avis
quel a été son rôle en capital vous
savez qu'il lui a dédicacé un de ses
livres en disant que sans elle rien
n'aurait été possible
et c'est vrai il ya d'abord le courage
extraordinaire il faut penser à la façon
dont elle a vécu à ce qu'elle a subi à
ses années d'exil aux attentats qu'elle
a si j'ose dire partager
il faut penser à ce drame ils ont vécu
incendie était celui de leur première
fille et qui est peut-être au monde la
chose qui les a le plus uni n'est ce pas
donc un courage tout à fait
extraordinaire qui la rendait à mon avis
beaucoup plus aptes qu'aucune aux autres
à aider le général mais il ne faut pas
croire qu'elle était effacée au point de
ne pas donner son avis à ses paras du
tout elle était tout à fait capable de
juger les gens et même je dirais de s'en
moquer gentiment mais jamais
publiquement pour pas que ces mots
soient répétées mais elle avait beaucoup
d'esprit je crois qu'elle ne concevait
son rôle que comme être si vous voulez
le soutien du président et en accepter
les activités extérieures que parce
qu'il le fallait
n a pas voulu imprimer sa marque dans le
décor ou dans ce genre de choses ça ne
l'intéressait pas beaucoup
j'ai appris à connaître je crois pouvoir
le dire à comprendre madame de gaulle
une certaine nuit de 1943 le général on
le sait très peu il n'en parlait jamais
avait contracté les fièvres lors d'un
atterrissage forcé dans la brousse
africaine au milieu d'un étang il fut
entre la vie et la mort je crois qu'on
peut aller jusque là puisqu'il disait
lui-même que seul docteur lifshitz un
héros de bir-hakeim se disent entre
parenthèses compagnons de la libération
l'avait tiré d'affaires
je les ai veillé pendant une nuit
entière recueillant certain nombre
d'instructions de messages de sa voix
naturellement même de gaulle et est à
son chevet et m'est apparu à l'heure
comme une pré tienne exemplaire sa
prière était transparente elle l avait
banni son comportement toute ostentation
et il m'a semblé percevoir le timbre
d'une âme qui ne pouvait pas ne pas
exercer par son rayonnement même une
influence sur le général le nouveau
ministre du travail a été nommé
aujourd'hui sur proposition du premier
ministre il s'agit de monsieur jean
matéo ligen matteoli qui depuis six ans
président et les charbonnages de france
et c'est la première fois patrice
duhamel que monsieur matteoli exercera
des fonctions gouvernementales
oui et c'est un gaulliste de 57 ans jean
matteoli donc qui remplace le gaulliste
robert boulin au ministère du travail et
de la participation c'est un père de
famille de six enfants il était jusqu'à
ce soir 18 heures heure de sa nomination
officielle président des charbonnages de
france un poste qu'il occupait donc
depuis six ans et où c'est à souligner
la situation sociale là était toujours
calme ces dernières années les accords
salariaux ayant été par exemple
régulièrement et sans problèmes majeurs
reconduit jean matteoli homme de
dialogue partisans de la participation
est à la fois un technicien et un
politique techniciens des affaires
sociales il a depuis longtemps des
relations suivies avec l'ensemble des
organisations syndicales
c'est aussi un spécialiste des questions
industrielles chargé notamment de 68 à
1972 de la conversion industrielle dans
la région du nord et du pas-de-calais et
donc a dit tout à l'heure raymond barre
direct avec les problèmes régionaux le
nouveau ministre du travail du
gouvernement raymond barre est aussi un
politique c'est un gaulliste de toujours
ancien secrétaire national de l'udps et
r conseiller dit gainey en 1976 est
chargé à l'époque d'un rapport sur la
participation
jean matteoli est aujourd'hui membre du
rpr et secrétaire général du carrefour
du gaullisme il devra maintenant très
vite approfondir un certain nombre de
dossiers d'actualité la situation de
l'emploi bien sûr mais aussi
l'aménagement de la durée du travail le
droit d'expression des travailleurs dans
l'entreprise la participation la réforme
de l'agencé nationale de l'emploi
et puis à très court terme la
préparation des élections prud'homales
du 12 décembre proche d'une manière
générale jean matteoli devra dans la
foulée des entretiens d'octobre dernier
entre raymond barre et les syndicats et
les organisations patronales approfondir
et développer le dialogue social
le ministre du travail est en même temps
le ministre la participation monsieur
matteoli a toujours été un homme fidèle
à l'idée de participation vous
connaissez ses sentiments à l'égard du
général de gaulle et il était normal
qu'après monsieur boulin dont nous
connaissions aussi tous les sentiments
ce soit un homme dont on ne puisse pas
discuter les sentiments et les jus en la
matière qui puisse être chargé de ce
dossier de la participation
aujourd'hui le président de la
république a reçu durant une heure le
garde des sceaux monsieur alain
peyrefitte et le président giscard
d'estaing a fait savoir l'importance
qu'il attache à ce que la procédure
judiciaire à propos de laquelle monsieur
robert boulin s'est donné la mort soient
poursuivis en toute indépendance jusqu'à
son terme et qu'aboutisse dans les
meilleurs délais un jugement qu'ils
soient connus de l'opinion publique
la suite de l'actualité politique
monsieur raymond barre tente de sortir
la discussion budgétaire de l'impasse il
a rencontré aujourd'hui les présidents
des deux groupes parlementaires de la
majorité à l'assemblée nationale et le
chef du gouvernement a indiqué à ses
interlocuteurs qu'il était prêt à
étudier avec eux toutes propositions
d'économies dans les dépenses de l'état
monsieur raymond barre leur a proposé la
formation d'un
groupe de travail à l'étranger la
séquestration par les étudiants
islamiques d'une soixantaine d'otages
américains provoquent des incidents sur
les campus universitaires aux états unis
des bagarres ont éclaté aujourd'hui
entre eux des étudiants américains et
leurs condisciples iranien favorable à
l'aléa taulard obeidi deux éléments
nouveaux aujourd'hui dans cette affaire
l'envoyé spécial du président carter que
l'imam khomeiny vous le savez ne veut
pas recevoir cet envoyé spécial s'est
arrêté à istanbul où il est entré en
contact avec un représentant de
l'organisation de libération de la
palestine l'information a été révélée
par un haut responsable américain
et puis d'autre part à téhéran les
étudiants islamiques ont exposé l'un des
otages devant les caméras de la presse
internationale
sur place notre envoyé spécial tiré de
scitivaux hier le prenait à espérer de
voir on est revenu au point mort aucune
discussion aucune négociation n'était
ouverte
on a demandé d'une part aux iraniens de
respecter les étrangers et de l'autre on
leur ex et pourquoi les diplomates
élisaient leurs stocks eia de la revue
accusé les états unis de la propagande
alors qu'elle est à présent c'était une
idée voilà pour le décor il deviendrait
en dinars le politique entend servir un
peu plus vils alors les flics radio
viendra elle et madras grec de vente de
l'ayatollah khomeiny et enfin en bolivie
le colonel bush qui a pris le pouvoir le
1er novembre dernier semble faire
machine arrière après avoir employé
durant quelques jours la manière forte
il annonce maintenant la libération des
prisonniers politiques la levée
prochaine de la loi martiale et puis il
promet que des élections auront lieu en
1981 ces gestes d'apaisement seront ils
suffisants pour calmer l'effervescence
politique bolivienne désormais
légendaire régis faucon lorsque les
chars font leur apparition dans les rues
de la paz les habitants de la capitale
bolivienne ne prête qu'une attention
distraite les coups d'état ils
connaissent ce petit pays du continent
sud américain détient le record peu
enviable de l'instabilité dans une
région pourtant la concurrence et
sérieuse en 154 années d'indépendance il
a connu quelques 200 changement de
régime
la durée moyenne d'un gouvernement et de
moins d'un an un jour de 1970 le pays a
changé trois fois de dirigeants en
l'espace de 24 heures dans la plupart
des cas il s'agit de règlements de
comptes au sein de l'armée un militaire
dit de droite chassaing militaires dits
de gauche qui se fait à son tour
renversé par un autre militaire encore
plus à droite
tout cela dans une certaine indifférence
car c'est bien sûr le peuple qui en fait
les frais même si on affirme toujours
vouloir intervenir en son nom et pour
son bien pourtant le dernier en date des
coups d'état est différent à bien des
titres la bolivie avait réussi très
péniblement à se donner un gouvernement
civil l'armée ayant accepté de regagner
les casernes dans le contexte bolivien
c'était un véritable exploit
hélas cette expérience devait être de
courte durée
trois mois seulement la semaine dernière
un certain colonel la touche bouche très
marqué à droite se déclaraient président
de la république
mais l'autre particularité de ce coup de
force et qu'il a déclenché une véritable
de boucliers à l'intérieur et à
l'extérieur du pays les syndicats ont
déclenché une grève générale les membres
du parlement et du gouvernement sont
entrés dans la clandestinité
une partie de l'armée elle même a refusé
de suivre le nouveau régime employer la
force et il y aurait eu des dizaines de
morts
et puis élément capital pour ces petits
pays andin depuis toujours surveillé de
très près par le grand voisin
nord-américain
washington a officiellement manifesté
son mécontentement l'administration
carter ne s'est pas contenté de déplorer
la fin du processus démocratique en
bolivie elle a suspendu une partie de
son aide
malgré ses déclarations apaisantes le
colonel la touche bouche et dans un
isolement tel qu'il est fort peu
probable qu'il puisse se maintenir
longtemps au pouvoir
en bref maintenant la suite de
l'actualité en votre compagnie gens
pressés présidentielle américaine un
nouveau candidat pour l'investiture du
parti démocrate le parti de ted kennedy
il s'agit du gouverneur de californie
edouard bronn jimmy carter lui il va
assister à la convention démocrate de
floride où il espère bien se faire
consacré face à son rival ted kennedy
qui a lui entamé officiellement sa
campagne comme le veut la tradition
politique américaine en publiant son
état de santé et sa feuille d'impôts ce
soir à 21h30 dans l'événement le
magazine d'henri marque christian
bernadac et julien besançon un portrait
de ted kennedy par dominique bromberger
au sommaire du magazine les témoignages
de ceux qui ont bien connu madame de
gaulle
enfin un document sur mère teresa prix
nobel de la paix réalisé par christian
brincourt à calcutta au zaïre 215 jeunes
âgés de 17 à 21 ans ont été massacrés
par des militaires dans la province du
kasaï oriental
le 19 juillet dernier il s'agit là d'
information parvenue au siège de la
fédération internationale des droits de
l'homme qui demande bien entendu les
explications au président mobutu
a paris une vingtaine de français
objecteurs de conscience parmi lesquels
15 insoumis recherché par la police ont
occupé l'ambassade de belgique il
demande de taux belges l'asile politique
définir un projet de société cohérent
afin de relever les défis des années 80
c'est l'objectif que se donne la 12e
convention nationale des clubs
perspectives et réalités le 17 novembre
prochain
c'est ce qu'a lancé aujourd'hui jean
pierre fourcade
le trafic aérien était pratiquement
nulle au dessus de la france en raison
des mouvements sociaux dans ce secteur
il ya d'abord la grève des contrôleurs
du trafic aérien puis d'autre part à air
france la grève des personnels navigants
et au sol qui a paralysé les mouvements
que la compagnie nationale a tenté
programmées toute la journée demain la
grève des contrôleurs aériens continus
alstom poursuite du mouvement c'est ce
qu'ont décidé les grévistes des usines
la situation on ne peut plus est on ne
peut plus bloquée malgré un premier
contact entre syndicats et direction
mais cette entrevue n'a pas permis de
déboucher sur l'ouverture de
négociations
a lyon ce sont les autobus et le métro
qui n'ont pas roulé en raison d'un arrêt
de travail des employés des transports
en commun poursuivant leurs recherches
après la collision hier de deux mirage 3
c au dessus des ardennes les sauveteurs
on retrouve aujourd'hui un avion et le
corps du pilote de l'un de ses avions
qui s'était écrasé le pilote de l'autre
avion où il savait avait réussi à faire
fonctionner son siège éjectable son
appareil malheureusement était allé se
disloquer sur trois maisons du village
de damouzy et de personnes avaient été
blessées dont une grièvement
le grand prix du roman de l'académie
française a été décerné à henri
coulonges pour son livre l'adieu à la
femme sauvage qui est publié aux
éditions stock
en pologne les vingt mineurs qui étaient
bloqués au fond de la mine silesia en
haute silésie
depuis le 30 octobre dernier ont été
retrouvés aujourd'hui son été retrouvé
mort par les équipes de sauvetage un
important accord de coopération a été
signé par monsieur antoine de clermont
tonnerre le pdg de la sfp et monsieur
jean louis guillot le pdg de tf1
il prévoit pour 1981 et 80 le
développement progressif des commandes
de tf1 la sfp
les deux sociétés ont décidé de
développer une politique de coproduction
qui contribuera à l'accroissement et au
renouvellement de la création télévisée
enfin pour gagner le tiercé mais elle
fait jouer le 6 le 14 et le 22
ils rapportent dans l'ordre pour 5
francs 3412 francs 5 ans du loyer sur
votre écran et dans un ordre différent
680 de francs 50 toujours pour 5 francs
bien entendu le temps pour demain avant
de refermer ce journal demain donc sur
les pyrénées les régions
méditerranéennes les alpes et le
nord-est une matinée pluvieuse et puis
dans l'après midi le temps deviendra
variable avec des
or plus fraîches le soir des orages
éclateront du sud des alpes à la corse
mais de belles éclaircies se
développeront sur le languedoc et la
provence sur tout le reste de la france
une matinée fraîche suivie d'un temps
variable avec alternance d'averses et
d'éclaircies
merci de votre attention à 23h10 joseph
poli vous présentera le dernier journal
passer une bonne soirée
demain à 20 heures vous retrouverez
roger gicquel